hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen and I
thought that I was going to be watching
Kirk Cameron's saving Christmas tonight
but I turned it on and literally could
not get through the first five minutes
so grandma got run over by a reindeer it
is has Christmas happens let me look at
my calendar sure has gues he saved
Christmas no need to do an episode on
Kirk Cameron's saving Christmas also I
thought it was a movie I don't I didn't
get very far into but I don't think it's
a movie I think it's just somebody
literally telling you what you should
feel about Christmas so get the fuck out
of here Kirk Cameron how's everyone do
any like Christian bashing but it was
like not my cup of tea so you know we're
doing the next best thing
another extremely religious film grandma
got run over by a reindeer I don't know
anything about this movie I was texting
Doug and he recommended it at first I
thought it was live-action know it's
animated guys I looked up the cutest
character I could find this is her
cousin Mel I think and so I don't know I
had no idea
is it good
[Music]
you
no no no no this is not good
yikes this was a bad bad bad bad movie
it was only 50 minutes which usually
thank you for the short movie I love
short movies this could have been
shorter the animation was terrible the
story was what was that story what is
happening what year is it what is
happening with their eyes
why do their eyes move when they're just
saying random oh my god it's happening
to me I can't stop it my favorite
Christmas story involves my grandma Lynn
a reindeer similar to me and my favorite
Christmas story involves my grandma and
spiced rum but then you actually see the
beginning of the story and grandma gets
whacked in the face with not not a
reindeer with the sleigh and some thick
gas reindeers some teenage ICC reindeers
and it looks like she died grandma
should be dead but resilient grandma got
run over by a reindeer the music sounds
I wasn't being dramatic it all sounds
terrible there's a bunch of songs of
this movie and they're all recorded
really really poorly okay they're all
recorded really really poorly and so it
sounds like somebody made them on
GarageBand and they are all like country
but like twangy country like old-timey
country it's a really cute premise
grandma owns this quaint little holiday
store where she sells quaint little
holiday decorations and it's in between
a bunch of giant buildings and this guy
named Austin big bucks or sweet wants to
buy it from her and she's like we don't
need that money because if you're nice
to people then you're rich and that's
what life is all about
so you see
and it's RIT's cute yeah totally
Christmas all about it definitely
definitely definitely yes yes yes on
board and I love cousin Mel's character
this mess of a going on
she's such a weird character she's very
breathy and everything that she says
overly sexy later in the movie she's
trying to sell the store because she
wants to be rich and she asks the
businessman Austin big bucks businessman
deluxe his full name
they don't say that movie but he's
signing the paper and she's like do you
wanna come to me this evening what's
going on in this weirdly animated
cartoon okay your first introduction to
cousin Mel which just made me the most
unsexy name I've ever heard of in my
life her first line is business woman
she doesn't want to sell her lifelong
own beautiful Christmas tour oh yeah
cousin Mel stick to your gun you're a
bad person yeah I just kind of roll with
it then you meet the little brother and
his sister his name is Jake and to be
honest I don't think I feel like she
walks into the room when he's like Oh
sisters she's like just when I thought a
computer nerd who still believes in
Santa you are so reality challenged
joke's on you early two-thousands movie
computer nerds are cool now then there's
a scene where they bring out the
Christmas tree and it's an inflatable
Christmas tree it's all the rage because
it's not cool to have a real tree did
you I protect all right they have this
newfangled tree and then this really
old-fangled camcorder to record the
first year they don't have a real tree
so dumb
Austin big bucks is walking around in a
troll costume so I think they thought
that was funny
he's like people are too busy for
Christmas with the cellular phones and
the fax machines
literally what he says not how he says
it I took artistic liberties there but
she's like no no Santa's still around
and Christmas still exists vice versa
cousin Melvin's over ago I've always
loved a man in what what yeah for sure
absolutely but what a lot of people have
cross eyes all the time meaning what
grandma does get drunk on eggnog and I
love it I'm here for it living and she
weaves and Santa hit-and-runs her
supposedly it's not really what happened
he left a note it's fine Jake the Sun I
think that's his name listen who knows
he sees that thing happen and he runs
out and he does the weirdest thing with
his eyes in this scene
he's like grandma just got hit by a
reindeer hurry
thank you sure I'm sorry I just realized
that the dog's name is doofus what's up
so grandma's missing for like four
months and cousin Mel is like oh well
now I can file the star and damned if
the writing is not terrible in this
movie than I'm do this no real doofus
all along
Austin big bucks is like you've got to
get granite bought a sign off on this
and she's like oh I can trick grep I
mean I can get grandpa to sign settle to
settle is this way
she goes to dinner with Grandpa and
she's like all you have to do is sign
and he's like sing no just she's like no
sign so sign side it's like I'd rather
sing and then he goes into a song number
and it's terrible and then it's again
he's like alright now I'm ready to sign
no no Jake finds out that the store is
about to be sold so he rollerblades all
the way across town to Austin big bucks
office where cousin Mel and her attorney
I am slime it's not a fee handed at all
if you were thinking that I am slime is
selling grandma's story it's not heavy I
don't know why you would think that cuz
it's not it just is it it's just not
then Jake thinks of a plan and you know
a lot of this movie has been maybe not
predictable but you know you could have
called when it happened so far this one
just really it's never been done in a
Christmas film before I don't think I'm
being serious he emailed the Santa Claus
and of course Santa being you know the
worldly man that he is also well versed
in technology he got the email and
responded to it then Jake goes to the
North Pole and finds grandma and can I
stop watching now please thank you so
much okay grandma has amnesia classic
Christmas story
she still agrees to come back and help
Santa agrees to come back and help -
thank goodness
then Santa's arrested thank goodness
what I don't know doofus sniffs out
grandma and finds her it's a terrible
sentence I forgot Mel captured grandma
again okay moving finally grandma's
memory is jobbed because she eats one of
her fruitcakes and Jake hugs her and
goes grandma you remember and then looks
streets the camera goes oh yeah what
Jake proof Santa's innocence then mr.
banks big banks Austin offers to
franchise grandma store which is like
still I feel like not something that she
wants but she's super excited about it
what the family comes to Jake and
they're like Jake you never gave up even
when all of us did well yeah you gave up
the morning she disappeared he stuck
with her for like less than a year it's
not that big of a feat jake is no saint
oh yeah oh yeah oh wow that was truly
mediocre Lee yeah and that concludes the
Tamara chambers
Tamara's never seen holiday extravaganza
thank you so much for watching I am
super excited to start a new year let me
tell you you know what I mean if you
feel me on that have a happy new year
thanks for watching bye say Happy New
Year bottles oh yeah hey
[Music]
[Applause]
you